bonjour bienvenue sur diagonale télé
spéciale grand champion de l'histoire du
fait des chèques avec notre spécialiste
de l'histoire
jérôme ou france les journalistes et
fans alors on va voir dans cette
émission un nouveau très très grands
champions puisqu'il s'agit encore d'un
champion du monde puisqu'on les voit
quand même quelques heures on les a tous
en collection maintenant il s'agit de
boris à skis et qui est connu non
seulement quand le champion du monde
d'échecs bien sûr comme tous les autres
mais encore peut-être plus
particulièrement puisque c'est lui qui a
joué le match du siècle face à bobby
fischer en 1972 mais avant d'en arriver
là on va voir un peu son parcours et son
parcours parce qu'il est né en 1937 à
leningrad c'est un ressortissant de
leningrad est très très jeune il est
confronté à la réalité de la vie et de
la guerre puisque à 5 ans en 1942 il est
évacué avec sa famille vers le district
de kirov puisque leningrad et sous la
menace de la wehrmacht suite à l'avancée
allemande après le début de l'opération
barbarossa qui a consisté comme tu le
sais à l'invasion surprise de l'urss par
les troupes d'hitler la rupture du pacte
germano-soviétique de 1938 exact avoir
eu l'accord ne peux pas te prendre en
défaut là dessus donc
la famille de boris spassky s'enfuit par
avec ses parents sa mère avec une
paysanne son père est un ingénieur
toujours des histoires d'ingénieur chez
les soviétiques
que ce soit les joueurs ou où les paires
de joueurs et il apprend tout jeune à
5-5 6 ans déjà à ce moment là à jouer
aux échecs
évidemment c'est dans un contexte un peu
troublé il faut attendre un petit peu de
temps pour qu'il se révèle vraiment il
al'occasion après la guerre de battre
mode vinik en simultané oui donc ça veut
dire qu'il était encore jeune et que le
mode de vie ni qui était en
démonstration voilà un messie ce qui est
amusant à noter c'est que beaucoup de
champions soviétiques ont commencé en
gagnant une simultanée je crois que bini
qui avait gagné en simultanée contre
capable en cas voilà les simultané sur
l'occasion pour de tout jeunes joueurs
de faire leurs premières armes contre
des maîtres renommée et peut-être que ça
lui a donné aussi le le goût de la
victoire et l' envie de continuer alors
il se révèle très jeune puisque il est
le plus jeune grand maître international
de tous les temps à l'époque ce qu'il
obtient son titre de grand maître
international à 18 ans en 1955 ce qui
est déjà très gênant il initie déjà dion
la précocité dans les champions qu en
fait un c'est le premier champion
précoce soit en tout cas le premier de
l'ère moderne on a eu des jeunes
prodiges comme ça mais la richesse ce
qui bien sûr qu'être trois étaient des
grands joueurs des dès l'âge de 7 8 9 10
ans mais il est le premier véritable
grand maître international officiel de
moins de 20 ans donc il est très très
précoce ce qui lui permet de voir de
voir un horizon importance ouvrir parce
que le grand maître 1 18 ans dans les
années 50 c'était l'assurance d'avoir
une d'avoir une carrière seulement il ya
un petit souci c'est qu'il ya d'autres
jeunes joueurs talentueux à cette époque
qui émergent en urss ou qui sont déjà un
petit peu plus lourd que lui qui sont
petrossian étals et qui va être barrée
pendant quelques temps par par ces deux
par ses deux grands champions qui naquit
le qui le bat régulièrement et qui eux
arrivent à se qualifier régulièrement
pour les cycles de championnat du monde
ce qui permet notamment à tall d'être
champion du monde à petrossian aussi
d'être champion du monde donc c'est pas
ce qui dans un premier temps après un
début assez fulgurant est un petit peu
freiné dans sa progression
il juge d'ailleurs utile de changer
d'entraîneur à ce moment-là et
changement de vie
c'est un peu anecdotique mais il quitte
sa femme à ce moment là il décide de
changer de vie de changer de méthode
d'entraînement parce qu'il sent qu'il
est un petit peu limité dans sa
progression
d'accord alors ça ça marche puisque en
1961 mais il arrive à remporter le
championnat du rss et se qualifie pour
le cycle des championnats du monde
déjà à l'époque on gagne et chocolat du
rss c'était déjà le signe qu'on allait
jouer un rôle dans les tous meilleurs
mondiaux et puisque le championnat du
rss il suffit d'y rajouter fischer à
l'époque et on a le championnat du monde
bon j'exagère un petit peu mais à peine
on a tous les grands joueurs de l'époque
des smiths love boat vinik talent
petrossian qui joue ce championnat du
rss et de fait montré qu'on est le plus
fort parmi les soviétiques ou en tout
cas un des plus forts c'est déjà être
candidat au titre mondial
et justement il se qualifie pour les
interzones o2 d'amsterdam en 64 il
arrive à passer le cycle des
qualifications et se retrouve contre le
champion du monde en titre tirant de
petrossian en finale en 1966 voilà donc
ça c'est ce premier achèvement déjà
arrivés en finale des championnats du
monde c'est déjà en soi bien rentrer une
entrée dans l'histoire puisque non mais
pour être un clown une fois robe gagner
ce match donc même mais même si on ne
gagne pas je dirais qu'ils n'ont pas
gagné qui sont rentrés l'histoire un
corse noël qui a joué deux fois car pose
non il n'a pas réussi à gagner le titre
mais de fait il fait partie de
l'histoire des champions du monde comme
étant combien était le challenger le
plus proche de la couronne mais sur donc
il joue peut être aussi un des 66 t 66
on y est
petrossian est encore au sommet de sa
forme et puisse pas ce qui n'est pas
encore tout à fait arrivé à maturité et
il doit baisser pavillon devant
l'arménien mais mais mais ne se départit
pas de sa persévérance et trois ans
après en 1969 il rencontre un nouveau
petrossian finale du championnat du
monde après s'être qualifiés et cette
fois ci ne laisse pas passer sa chance
et une ba petrossian et devient champion
du monde donc ça c'est fort parce que on
est à une époque où petrossian il
considérait man et bien sûr et
championne mais surtout considéré comme
le jour le plus solide de l'histoire
c'est le joueur qui perd le moins deux
parties qui est considéré comme un bloc
défensif indépassable est ce parce qu'il
est quand même le chemin de ronde qui la
kia qui a percé la muraille 1 c'est ce à
quoi s'est séparé le bois c'est c'était
quand même une grande une grande
réussite
et puis là pour dire d'une certaine
façon qu'il levait une chape de plomb
puisque toutes les années 60 on était
quand même assez dominé par petrossian
dont le style très défensif a fait des
émules puisque finalement quand un
champion du monde est très défensif m'a
beaucoup de joueurs se disent c'est
sûrement la meilleure façon de faire et
on peut dire que parce qu'il a aussi
ouvert la porte à des échecs peut-être
plus dynamique oui clairement oui on
peut dire que de spa ce qui
effectivement qu'il est le précurseur de
l'ère moderne ou financer dynamisme qui
va l'emporter le dynamisme c c'est
finalement la brute moyenne entre le
trop défensif et le trot le troupeau
offensif
c'est la moyenne entre les hyper moderne
et les romantiques j'ai envie de dire
c'est vraiment là c'est la bonne c'est
ce qui a été considéré longtemps qu'on a
la bonne la bonne technique qui va
exploser les fisher qui va être suivi
par kasparov et on en est c'est ce sont
les joueurs dynamiques qui sont les
héritiers de 7
de cette voie de la du dynamisme dans
les échecs pour espèces qui a marqué
l'histoire il n'est pas resté champion
du monde très très longtemps puisque en
1972 se dresse devant lui un concurrent
très sérieux puisqu'il s'agit de bobby
fischer qui s'estqualifiée en battant en
quarts de finale b larsen 4 060 en
battant taille madoff en demi finale 6 0
et en battant en finale petrossian 6 2
donc c'est américain en pleine forme en
pleine ascension et qui avait fait un
retour fulgurant dans les échecs que
doit affronter ce pas ce qui nous passe
qui n'est pas spécialement effrayé par
le match parce qu'il avait un résultat
positif contre fischer à ce moment là
oui c'est vrai donc il se disait qu'en
définitive il n'y avait pas de raison
lui même été champion du monde il était
au sommet de sa forme donc
l'affrontement valait le coup d'être
jouée en tout cas il se sentait pas
battu du tout d'avancé mais un match au
camp boulet skf quand même blessé ce
match qui a fait la une des médias du
monde entier
alors avec bien sûr toutes les
revendications de fisher qui a imposé
ses conditions des rats en plus même le
lieu du match aller à la création elle a
fait l'objet de longues tractations mais
les joueurs ont pensé à belgrade dans un
premier temps bon sa convenance parce
qu'ils aimaient bien us la vie fischer
aimait beaucoup la yougoslavie en dépit
du fait qu'elle se trouvait plutôt du
côté soviétique mais elle avait une
relative indépendance et surtout les
yougoslaves sont très fan d'échecs et
comprenait bien aimé le jeu de fisher
donc les deux se sentait bien joué à
belgrade et puis finalement ça ne s'est
pas fait le match et il a été décidé que
ce jour à reykjavik très très longtemps
on n'a pas su s'il allait véritablement
avoir lieu ce match un peu de guerre
froide en pleine guerre froide on est on
est un des sommets à une apogée de la
guerre froide la tension entre les
soviétiques et américains est très très
forte danger nucléaire epr on est dans
tous les esprits dans tous les esprits
les soviétiques son centre est très
raide sur leurs positions pour perdre le
championnat du monde d'échecs entre un
américain c'est absolument inconcevable
à ce moment du à ce moment de l'histoire
c'est absolument inconcevable d'autant
plus que les médias pour une des
premières fois les grands médias
s'intéressent à ce match qui apparaît
comme un zoom sur la guerre froide oui
c'est une certaine façon de de
suprématie intellectuelle idéologie qui
se joue quelque part un peu sur
l'échiquier et qui peut avaliser ou pas
la suprématie politique s'est par
ailleurs ça va donner l'occasion à un
des deux camps de parader en disant que
son système produit les cerveaux les
plus brillants
il ya certes arrière-pensée qui était
très très très très réel au point que
quand fischer a donné des quelques
signes inquiétants
de ne pas jouer ce match puisqu'on il a
disparu dans les jours qui ont précédé
le match
nixon a dépêché kissinger pour retrouver
fisher et pour le convaincre de jouer
lui a envoyé un télégramme en lui disant
vous êtes défenseur du monde libre vous
devez jouer c'était c'était très très
important même pour les américains qui
ne mettait pas avant autant d'importance
dans le jeu d'échecs que les soviétiques
mais pour ce match là il y avait
vraiment une pression très très forte
fischer les deux joueurs eux-mêmes
s'apprécient beaucoup par ailleurs il
s'appréciait vous n'avez pas de
problèmes entre eux ni du point de vue
voilà du point de vue politique ni
autres il n'avait pas de succès
d'ailleurs
avant le match on vit tous les deux on
ne fait pas de politique il voulait pas
rentrer dans ce jeu là il n'avait pas de
dîner métier comme il ya pu y en avoir
entre entre d'autres joueurs comme corps
je travaille petrossian par ailleurs ce
match il a commencé de façon
rocambolesque que tu as dis parce que il
a commencer déjà par une défaite de
fisher alors dans une position qu'on
considère quasi nul il a il allait
prendre un pion avec son fou de façon
plus que téméraire est pire que ça il ne
s'est pas privée ne s'est pas présenté
pour la deuxième partie ce qui fait que
ce pass qui a nom a rapidement mené 2 0
ce qui ce qui semble être un avantage
presque presque décisive et d'une
certaine façon beaucoup de commentateurs
après on dit que c'était une sorte de
gambie de la part de fisher parce qu'il
a il a donné quasiment deux parties
espace qui met la page à 6 passes qui
dans des conditions psychologiques tels
des conditions
qui faisaient que ce pas ce qui s'est vu
gagner relativement facilement n'était
pas sûr que fisher seraient présents
même pour la troisième partie
donc il ya un petit peu sortis du match
il l'a fait peut-être un peu sortir du
match
et puis à chaque fois que fisher avait
une exigence leuthard schmitt les
arbitres avaient demandé à ce parce
qu'ici ça le dérangeait pas est ce parce
qu'ils vont garçon disait que ça ne le
dérangeait pas eu d'une certaine façon
parce qu' après dit j'ai accepté
beaucoup trop de choses où il a regretté
sert beaucoup plus tard il a dit
j'aurais pas dû pas dû accepter position
en charge de salles qu'on change de
pièce quand fassi qu'en face ça parce
qu'en définitive
fischer avait
voilà faisait ce qu'il voulait et puis
moi je disais oui et il a regretté après
coup
et de fait le jour il n'a pas donné le
meilleur de lui-même au cours de ce
match c'est quand même un très grand
match avec des parties très brillante
que fisher fini par remporter c'est
parce qu'il ya une quand même deux
autres partis il me semble donc c'est ce
sera le match fini 6 3 ses chronos kz2
gagner à une autre en cours je crois que
c'est la grande préparation sur la
sicilienne qui était dans les labos
russe montre contre justement le point
pour raisonner de kant été empoisonnés
de fisher mais je crois c'est 6,3 m sans
la vérifier
c'est pas sujet de l'émission mais bon
il n'en reste pas moins que ce match
était très important est le retour de ce
parce qu'ils en urss s'est un peu
compliqué parce que il reste celui qui a
perdu le titre mondial contre un
américain
oui ce qui en 72 suffit à lui poser des
problèmes vis-à-vis des autorités
soviétiques faut quand même rappeler que
tous les joueurs tous les grands joueurs
soviétiques sont des professionnels au
sens où ils sont fonctionnaires de
l'état soviétique lui ils sont payés en
tant que sportif quand il renverse le
regard la fédération soviétique et tout
ce qu'ils ont en gros dépens de leurs
résultats et de la bonne ou mauvaise
opinion que les autorités soviétiques
ondes et après la défaite de 72 espace
qui n'est pas persona non grata mais il
est considéré comme celui qui a fait
perdre le titre
donc ça devient très très difficile pour
lui pourtant ils arrivent ils arrivent à
être encore champion du rss dans les
années 70 mais la pression est de plus
en plus forte sur ses épaules et en soit
il est quand même de nouveau en finale
des candidats
c'est à dire que ces cars postaux
en fait il est en demi finale des
finales mais c'est quelque chose qui les
passent devant
oui ce qui est sûr c'est que la finale
des candidats c'est karpov corp chinalco
cloud et 6e match à déterminer en fait
le champion du monde puisque fisher ne
s'est pas présenté demi finales mais il
a été en demi finale et puis même en en
80 il est encore présent mais dans les
allées sont en lice la pression
était-elle en union soviétique que la
finit par partir il est venu s'installer
en france à meudon qui plus est il avait
rencontré une française d'origine russe
qui travaillait à l'ambassade et les
autorités soviétiques ils y ont demandé
la jeune femme de partir ce parce qu'il
a décidé de partir avec elle
oui alors ça ça a été une chance alors
ça c'est la fin de la carrière de baskuy
mais c'était une chance aux échecs en
france français puisqu'il a fait pas il
a été un des premiers grands maîtres
russes à venir s'installer véritablement
en france et il a bénéficié il a fait
bénéficier l'équipe de france de son de
son expérience puisqu'il a joué avec
l'équipe de france il devenu français et
il a pu
comme ça jouer un rôle d'émulation
auprès de tous les jeunes les jeunes
pousses françaises et il a il a expliqué
aussi parce que forcément quand on quand
on joue en équipe avec des joueurs bien
l'analyse bellon explique ça c'est des
choses précieuses qu'ils ne peuvent pas
se transmettre facilement quand ceux qui
savent sont en russie à ses yeux que
quand ceux qui savent ne sont pas loin
mais parce que l'émulation entre quand m
soviétique est évidente
la plupart des champions du monde ont eu
pour entraîneur un ancien champion du
monde ce qu'il faut pas oublier que
c'était à ce type au clan plus en france
on n'a pas de grands maîtres on n'a même
pas de m il n'y a pas encore de maître
puisque aldo haïk qui est premier maître
international français je crois qu'il
réalise sa troisième normes de maître
international en 1978 donc quand brice
pas ce qui arrive en france en 1975 76
il n'y a pas un seul maître
international n'a rien du tout à telle
enseigne que on en a cherché il y a
aucun joueur français qui ait joué
contre bobby fischer oui non aucun pas
étonnant oui on a pas on n'a pas de
témoignages n'ont qu'à pas d'histoire en
fait à ce moment-là il n'y a pas de
modèle de réussite pour les échecs
français définit dehors mais sa date
mais ça l'a longtemps de la vème siècle
donc c'est un modèle de réussite trop
lointain pour pour que ce soit encore un
qui va ça ce moment là l'équipe à
l'équipe bien sûr qui est aussi un effet
d'entraînement dans les années 30 40 sur
les échecs français
mais c'est vrai que ce pas ce qui va
permettre l'éclosion de cette de cette
génération sera celle d aldo haïk puis
ensuite des oliviers rooney et joël
lautier joël lautier
et ainsi de suite premier mieux que
l'outil a joué en équipe de france avec
ce casting
oui et je crois qu'ils étaient dans le
même club à un moment
a lyon c'est un vieux boris spassky
quand ils arrivent en france on a
l'impression qu'il est quasiment la
retraite mais en réalité les plus
champion du monde que depuis quatre ans
c'est encore un immense joueur
mary remporte le tournoi de linares en
1983 il participe aux olympiades
bon il est vrai que la tendance ensuite
dans les années 80 se contenter
quelquefois deux parties nulles le
patois pas trop pousser les parties et a
ajout sinon en dilettante en tout cas
être moins acharnée dans le travail que
d'autres grands joueurs ce qui explique
qu'il ait eu des relativement moindre
performance par la suite mais ça reste
un joueur d'expérience et un joueur de
très haut niveau
le très haut niveau qui ça fait partie
de la dalle vraiment de la légende du
xxème siècle des échecs avec ce fameux
cette fameuse ce fameux match
extraordinaire face à fischer qui
d'ailleurs a eu une revanche puisque
vingt ans plus tard en 92 a lieu le
match revanche fischer spassky en pleine
guerre de yougoslavie en pm dans clem un
plein l'embargo de yougoslavie mais il
ya eu quand même ma qu'ils ont ils ont
refait ce match pour pour en fait pour
faire la nique aux américaines soyons
clairs je crois que c'est ça qui s'est
passé c'est à dire que bobby fischer
avait un caractère quand même très
particulier s'est sentie oui c'est
toujours senti un petit peu utilisé par
par les américains donc il a accepté de
jouer le jeu
tant qu'il était champion du monde
autant que cela lui permettait de
lettres et ensuite il a rapidement pris
ses distances en fait avec avec les
autorités américaines
et c'est vrai qu'en 92 il ya
vraisemblablement une part de
provocation chez fisher à vouloir
absolument jouer ce match en yougoslavie
alors qu'elle est sous embargo
oui enfin c'est là qu'ils proposaient la
bourse pour le faire parce qu'on est
revenu ça oui ils ont appelé ça
championnat du monde de nous oui c'est
parce qu'il a joué ce match n'était pas
mal ce match d'ailleurs si on regarde
les parties et le match il était tout à
fait intéressant puis tout le monde
rêvait de revoir fischer condom n'avait
plus entendu parler quasiment depuis
depuis 20 ans et qui était partie dans
la brousse oui pour les pour les grands
fiches profils qui nous regardent
peut-être et pour tout ce qu'ils ne
savent pas il y à des américains la
plupart des américains considéraient en
92 que bobby fischer était toujours
champion du monde oui puisqu'il ne s'est
pas présenté il a été destitué de son
titre par la fidh et mais n'a jamais
perdu son titre sur l'échiquier nos
idées et en 1986 le congrès américain a
voté une motion
ouais stipulant que bobby fischer était
toujours champion du monde d'échecs le
congrès américain bon c'est au congrès
car le congrès c'est comme le sénat ou à
l'assemblée nationale en france
parce que à l'époque de reagan qui était
ultra nationalistes et qui était qui
était on était encore dans la guerre
froide
ça coûtait pas cher d'en remontrer un
petit peu aux soviétiques en feu votants
cette motion mais il y avait une part de
la population américaine qui considérait
que de toute façon tant qu'il n'avait
pas perdu sur l'échiquier il était
toujours champion du monde et le match
de 92 dans l'esprit de bobby fischer je
pense est la suite logique
oui le
du championnat du monde le match
revanche et on recommence mais bon ce
parce qu'ils le jouent il est content de
voir fichier je crois qu'il a toujours
dit qu'il considère comme un ami et
bon ben voila et après il ya ce qui n'a
pas été lui inquiété par les autorités
françaises alors que fisher a été
inquiété par les autorités américaines
de son côté donc il est revenu en france
sans problème et il a continué sa case
sa carrière ici en france alors on va
voir quelques photos de boris spassky
ici donc voilà une première photo qui
date des années 80 c'est 1980 je crois
que c'est une photo des olympiades de
malte mohr à la boris spassky voilà on
va passer à lorsqu'elle est sourd non je
crois que oui je sais plus lequel ces
noms pas ma connaissance n'est pas clair
donc voilà alors ça c'est parce qu'il ya
encore un peu plus âgés alors à noter
qu' on est en août
en août 2012 et que boris spassky tout
récemment a encore vécu une expérience
de sa vie rocambolesque puisque il a fui
la france lui carrément il fait une lame
est en tout cas un
c'est ainsi qu'il le dit c'est ainsi
qu'il a que ça a été dit dans l'est dans
les journaux russes qui ont relayé
l'information
il a fui la france parce que il avait le
sentiment depuis deux ans d'être enfermé
chez lui en fait parmi ses idées mais
c'est vrai que depuis de nous on entend
plus parler
oui il serait c'est à dire qu'il a eu un
élagueur problèmes graves problèmes de
santé en 2006 2007 il a été soigné pour
ça et ensuite l'y aider là il s'est
enfui parce qu'il disait qu'il était
assigné à résidence en fait ouais qu'ils
savaient pas vraiment si on l'avait bien
soignée qui comprenait pas exactement ce
qui s'était passé il a plus ou moins
laissé entendre aux journaux russes
qu'on voulait abréger sa vie non non je
ne sais pas qui mais voilà et qu'il
avait peur aussi qu'on ait enlevé son
héritage alors qu'ici les disait qu'il
s'estime bon paf a spécialement riche et
que c'est vrai qu'à la fois il dit
quelque chose ils sont contre hénin
beaumont bref mais bon bref il semble
avoir vécu une période un peu
particulière puisqu'il a donc quitté la
france c'est tout récent ça date de quoi
y avait les quelques jours de semaine et
qu'ils se retrouvent de nouveau
maintenant en russie alors ces deux faut
dire qu'aujourd'hui on vit aussi une
période avait des tensions
internationales particulière mais voilà
donc ce parce qu' un nouvel épisode de
sa vie rocambolesque dont la biographie
sera sans doute
très intéressante il écrit un jour on
attend la sortie de son autoradio ça
sera tout à fait intéressant et voilà
enfin une photo encore dont boris
spassky dont un très grand joueur mais
sur photos dès les années 80 c'est peut
être 1984 il me semble aussi que c'est
aux olympiades sous les couleurs de
l'équipe de france voilà donc on va
revenir sur le plateau et puis je vais
passer sur notre échiquier pour voir
cette partie du championnat du monde
entre boris spassky et petrossian
évidemment parce qu'on regarde une
partie où se passe qui finalement m'est
a ravi le titre de champion du monde à
tigran petrossian qui le détient depuis
à ce moment là depuis 6 ans puisqu'ils
détiennent depuis 63 et donc ce pas ce
qui arrive en finale dans ce cycle de
champion du monde face à ce petrossian
et on est en plein match avec ce parce
qu'il est blanc et qui ouvre le jeu par
eux quatre ces cinq alors pas très
habituel chez petrossian et qui lui qui
choisit la défense sicilienne et une
ligne de jeu plutôt tendus tranchent et
alors qu'on le connaît plutôt pour le
louvoiement la prophylaxie et des coûts
tranquille
voilà on doit plutôt des françaises ou à
la limite des carreaux kahn sont plus
dans le style de
de pétrole il a joué des six il est
nommé sur un an kossi donc cavalier
trois des six sont nés dans une major du
nom du grand joueur argentin polonais à
lantin absolument des quatre s'éprend
des quatre caves les prendre quatre tout
ça est normal qu'elle lève six attaques
le pion central il faut le défendre donc
avait laissé trois le défend à six coups
typique de la nage dorff
l'idée étant d'empêcher bien sûr alors
qu'ils avaient les blancs de pouvoir on
en brèche tout contrôler toute
possibilité de venir y compris nos
fonctions au club des cinq et puis on
prépare aussi la poussée des cinq qui
est un thème classique il devait 5 aussi
cédé 4 attaqué ce cavalier qui devra
bouger et donc pression sur le pion
central
tout est là où j'ai cinq donc vous g5 va
contre cette idée puisque on attaque
nous à notre tour mais finalement
l'attaquant nous attaquer l'attaquant la
défense le meilleur défense c'est
l'attaqué
et puis ça pose une question c'est que
le yen menace et éventuellement de
prendre avec quelques pions les noirs
reprendrait mais effectivement on peut
envisager de prendre et puis ça se casse
la structure adverse est possible qu'à
elle et b17 or c'est logique est allée b
17 ici alors secoué toujours quasiment
jouer dans la neige devant off alors ici
ça peut éventuellement reprendre un fils
en cas de prise mais aussi tôt ou tard
ce qu'elle n'a envie de venir sur la
casse c'est simple pour contribuer à
l'attaqué sur le pion de leucate c'est
tout à fait dans l'idée de cette
variante poussé 4 alors ça c'est un coup
à l'ancienne technique ça se joue plus
trop le fait de ce faux listings
et vous c'est 4 on ne prend pas alors ce
fou ces cas très classique aussi dans
cette ouverture l'idée c'est de taper
sur cette petite faiblesse là
des débutants savent bien que le pion à
vii traits du roi tant qu'on n'a pas ok
c'est toujours un peu chatouilleux
c'est le seul pion qui ne soit défendue
que par que par le roi qui sur lequel on
peut faire des échecs sur lequel on peut
provoquer les infiltrations
ça peut être extrêmement pénible dame à
5 alors damas cinq est intéressant
puisque 1
ça cloue de cavale et c3 donc sacré la
menace cavalli prend 1,4 brute menaces
et en plus et 2 attention le fou et
emprise ça attaque le fou alors le coup
qui parlait de menaces il est simple
c'est d'amener de la d2 il n'y a plus de
clouage si les noirs prennent à laquelle
je peux prendre du cavalier et en plus
eh bien je défends le fou j'ai cinq
c'est le coup parfait logique est
parfait h6 alors h6 vont c'est un coup
de tickets stion c'est le fameux coup de
questionnements du fou alors là sur 1,6
après on a le choix on pour on peut
envisager de jouer faux h4 pourquoi pas
mais ça laisse là honorent la
possibilité du jury j'essaye tant qu'ils
ont par ok on sait pas trop où ils
peuvent aller dans ce type de rente
parfois les noirs font nos gros qu'on
n'est pas obligé de faire le pont du
rock
d'autant plus qu'il est probable que les
blancs face le camp rock
alors il ya exactement un mois bien
qu'ici les relais bleus choix mais il
fallait en général ils vont vous cette
ouverture pour attaquer donc on aimait
jouer le grand roque et ensuite essayer
de balancer les pions et la tacle à 6
donc là lui parce qu'il joue la joue
je dirais version développement rapide
puisqu'il fait carrément fou prend m6 en
faisant ça il perd pas de temps non
parce que si je vous vois je pétris
laisse les noirs choisir un autre coup
là il prend tout de suite car les
problèmes si ce grand roque a très bien
donc là alors là les bleus ont fini leur
développement les tours sont liés on a
une belle position centrale un joli
pions regarder que le centre ait bien
contrôlé par les blancs on a une belle
diagonale ici pour le fou et bombay
on a souvent envie de jouer encore au
roi bien parce que ça permet de bien
contrôler tous les pions et de mettre le
roi l'abri de toute possibilité ceci dit
avec le pouce et 4 ça va encore ouais le
fou exactement ces cas pompe contre la
deux le câble est aussi mais il n'ya pas
que ça c'est qu'on a joué 6 on n'a pas
peur de coups de fouet si ce qui ferait
des échecs ultérieure donc c'est pas
c'est pas forcément pressés de jouer des
coups droits mais un même si c'est
souhaitable mais surtout bon mais je
pense que les le plan des blancs
maintenant on va pouvoir s'éclaircir
est-ce que je vais jouer au centre est
ce que je vais tenter pourquoi pas des
coups comme f3 g4 h4 et puis c'est de
percer ici de ce côté de faire des
ruptures
c'est un peu long parce que tout ça est
loin donc il faut jouer beaucoup de
coups de pions voilà mais en tout cas
les blancs vont pouvoir commencer
maintenant a indiqué leur leur planche
puisqu'ils ont fini
alors regardez en échange de quoi les
noirs ils ont quand même et encore deux
fois la maison de tours à la maison ne
sont pas encore ok donc sans gros retard
de développement ils ont que deux pièces
de sortie mais ils ont une position
solide qui est difficile d'aller
chercher parce qu'il ya pas de contact
direct un contact et lointains ou 6
alors 6 et classique aussi à l'âge d'or
alors que six c'est normal on a envie
domtar de sortir le fond 1,7
éventuellement de roquet et parfois on a
aussi envie de jouer des cinq mais là
c'est pas possible avec le fou fou
lequel eric leroy au centre c'est pour
essayer d'ouvrir le jeu non mais pas
tout de suite mais ce sera l intérieur
et des choses qui sont plus tard parfois
donc lui aussi ce aussi en bouche
l'action du fou sur f7 c'est dire qu'on
peut tenter maintenant fou 17 et grand
roque sans craindre fou prend f7 donc
c'est un coup logique alors à noter que
le pion des six est à moitié faible dans
cette variante puisque bombay
il n'est pas protégé c'est une cible on
a deux pièces contre lui mais mais il ya
un trou qui suffit à redon il ya un fou
qui suffit à la protection ici il me
faut et suite puisqu'on voit pas trop
comment un cavalier pourrait venir
attaquer ce pion bc kiev 5 clés de son
son prix sauf si tous rachats et oui
parce que leurs six tours à chevenon
pourquoi pas tant dans la chasse comme
ça puisque la prise priest échec
et là c'est plus la même il faut
réfléchir c'est la cola il peut y avoir
des choses il peut conseiller dans des
tactiques
donc on est il ya vis-à-vis tout droit
et visite au roi mais il vaut mieux pouf
éviter révisé et préparer rapidement le
rock pour se dégager de ce vis-à-vis qui
est toujours porteur de danger le
toujours dans le début de la partie même
si la position est complexe et
maintenant c'est parce qu'ils donc en
tout cas donné qu il veut pas la tata
sur le côté il attaqué au centre il a
bien protégé son centre à noter que la
tour 1 aussi contrôlant le pion on n'a
pas peur de bayssan b4 qui déstabilise
le cavaly puisqu'on contrôle ici donc f4
très bien donc avancer maintenant f4
l'intérêt des f4 en fait c'est d'aller
buter ici pouf 25
pourquoi pour attaquer ceux qui ont eu
six parce que ce qu'ils ont et cissé
sous pression des cavaliers il est sous
pression du fou d'accord et s'il vient à
bouger en scène par exemple ou s'il
vient apprendre à bien ça libère toute
la grande diagonale
du fou qui va taper notamment sur f7 et
en transparence sur un roi qui serait
patient g8 donc f5 et un coup jeudi à
thématique dans toutes ses variantes de
5 et peut-être aussi envisageable on
peut envisager aussi avec les blancs y
compris la pousser au sein de ses deux
pouces et son possible et c'est pénible
pour un joueur car les noirs de devoir
réfléchir à chaque coup
si cette poussée ou l'autre n'est pas
une poussée pénible donc il faut
calculer à chaque fois petit rock pour
l'ordinateur c'est pas fatiguant mais
pour mon esprit si un peu donc petit
rock
alors petit re pourquoi pas alors à
noter que quand on a joué à six mais le
petit roquet déjà un peu faible oui ça
veut dire que des poussées comme g4 g5
et crée tout de suite une ouverture des
colonnes et puis les tours maintenant
qu'elles savent que le roi d'ys côté
elle aimerait bien ouvrir le jeu et puis
venir se positionner le long d'une
colonne ouverte face au roi et puis le
sueur froide espace des blancs qu'on
appelle le camp blanc est en fait
l'espace qui est derrière leurs pions là
jusqu'à la 4e rangée ce qui signifie que
la tour d 1 par exemple pourrait monter
alors j'ai 3 via des trois examens
détroit est alors j'ai trois pour
doubler voilà où la tour c ou la tour e
mais on peut venir effectivement tout à
fait en trois et coulisses et son âge
trois parfois soit parfois en g3 et
créer des menaces après des attaques par
dessus en fait c'est de pioncer on se
place au dessus de ses deux pions pour
venir coulisses est attaqué on n'est pas
obligé d'aller casser d'abord pour se
mettre derrière on peut aussi attaquer
sur la troisième rangée
tout ça est thématique donc four b3
avance parce qu'il se pressent pas et
consolide à bord sa position c'est un
conte prophylactique on évite de se
faire chasser le fou à noter aussi plus
foncé qu'à traiter ce qu'on appelle en
l'air ça veut dire donc potentiellement
emprise bon avant de se lancer dans les
complications il vaut mieux éviter
d'avoir une pièce qui a en fait
variantes se retrouvent
oui en prison
on pourrait toujours même si là c'est
pas forcément envisageable imaginez qu'à
un moment les noirs au même puisque 5 ce
qui attaquent le cavalier après quoi il
joue par exemple fou g4 pour attaquer la
tour d un et puis enfin deux variantes
tour c8 qui attaquent le fou encore une
séquence de harcèlement qui obligerait
boris spassky à réfléchir à chaque fois
mais plus mais a surtout à subir et à
répondre
voilà qu'en jouant tous les trois de
façon prophylactique il les ventes un
petit peu cette possibilité et didier au
noir qui ont moins de possibilités que
lui et bas à toi de jouer
exact donc ici le coup suivant
petrossian est aussi thématique de cette
position ils jouent tour huit tours et 8
alors c'est un conte classique
alors quelle idée tour huit bombes et un
ça peut contribuer à la défense de 6 ha
c'est vrai mais aussi ça libère la case
f8 pour le fou ou parfois même la case
f8 pour le cavalier c'est à dire qu'on
peut aussi envisager dans certaines
configurations de mettre le cavalier ici
pour protéger les cases pré du roi le
fou le cavalier donc c'est un coup à la
fois de centralisation de la tour et
aussi de dégagement on la met pas en des
8 parce que peut-être qu'on a envie de
mettre l'autre tours plus tard en dix
huit donc qu'on ne veut pas surcharger
les cases dont crois bien alors ça on
l'avait dit tout à l'heure on aime bien
dans ce type d'opposition mais
clairement mieux même si là je suis pas
sûr que ce soit vraiment passé la
prophylaxie de prophylaxie de la wii
voilà c'est vraiment histoire de bien
bien préparer la suite parce que bon
c'est pas une absolue nécessité bon à
noter quand même que vu qu'on a joué six
ans peut avoir maintenant qu'on a joué
vous hausse est un point d'appui
ici c'est que si on affaiblit en juin 25
la main
un clouage e pénible si les noirs jouant
e 5 e même il pourra faire sortir le
pion poussent en tout cas voilà sur
jossien qu'on va faire bouger ça il se
fou peut se trouver bien placés en gsm
donc il vaut mieux éviter des clous âge
qui sort et des mauvaises nouvelles donc
faux et fuite maintenant que tous les
noirs voient que de toute façon on ne
peut pas tout et il met comme on a dit
le fou donc on l'a vu que ce tous coûté
bien un coup de dé veloppement dégagé
voyez que la tour et bien non elle elle
fait un vis-à-vis noir améliorer leur
position on peut dire quand même que les
blancs ont atteint un bon potentiel de
développement de leurs pièces et de
leurs structures de pions avec tout et
développées j'ai été développée tout est
protégé surprotégé plus il n'y a pas de
point d'entrée dans l'ain quand blanc à
2b 2c de tous assez protégé surprotégé
du reste ya que la dame a cinq qui
pourrait créer un semblant de menaces
maintenant c'est l'heure du leurre du
cookie qui initie les phases de jeu
isaac c'est l'heure de dire
quelles sont nos intentions bel et bien
l'intention c'est parce qu'il est clair
g4 voilà alors ça c'est un coup très
fort puisque leurs scènes sacrifice de
pions puisque le pion est en prison peut
envisager de le prendre avec lecavalier
mais surtout bons bsa1 menace d'aller
jouer j'ai cinq est menacée tout de
suite une prise enrichissent l'ouverture
de toutes les lignes face au roi et
après on peut commencer à ramener les
tours maintenant qu'ils ont fini leur
travail aux saintes pourquoi pas
pourrait revenir sur le côté on peut
aussi voyager des manoeuvres comme tour
trois tours j'ai un plateau gt3 qui
viennent poupe pushs de tours angers
troyes où je crois au choix sans la
situation et on veut aller mater le roi
sans compter que la dame est en
embuscade le fou contre l'union zonale
attention le potentiel attaque blanc est
très fort oui parce que là sur une
poussée g5
on aurait par exemple s'il scipion prend
alors oui j'ai donc les bleu et noir ou
un coup comme fou 17 par exemple voilà
mettant en joue g5 un regard des bombes
et la prise est quasiment forces éprises
prises ou valcava y est déjà
imaginons qu'il aille en allergie 4
pourquoi pas doit déjà poussé trouver
des objets s'ils savaient voilà c'est ça
on peut pousser g6 pourquoi parce que
ben dunn le pion bien sûr mais surtout
regarder on a tous et derrière le fou
qui par transparence va créer une
attaque à regarder c'est très très fort
donc si on prend là on déloge de roi et
si ce sont les noirs qui prend regardez
déjà on a ouvert tout le jeu sur le roi
et il suffit de jouer des coups comme
maintenant tour g1 le cavalier ici par
exemple l'avenir en cinq et on continue
la tacc par par exemple des coups comme
danger 2 des coups assez appris comme
cavalier f3 pour déloger ces cavaliers
de 5 et la pression est à son maximum
possible aussi on va envisager les
manoeuvres classique de type carrière
deux cavaliers s4 et pouf on va aller
attaquer le pion j'ai cru 2009 avec 2 g
5 et cavaliers f5
on peut aussi en mai
des manoeuvres comptables puisque il
sera probable que par le plonger voilà
je efforts mais le jeu est fort ya
beaucoup de possibilités
le jeu est fort donc la petroci à bombay
il faut faire un choix
ça veut pas dire que ce qu'on a vu c'est
pas jouable il faut calculer en tout cas
ça fait peur alors lui il se dit mais
bon ok il ya une attaque mais au moins
ce qu on dit souvent dans une attaque
prend très bien je prends le pion je
réfléchisse a pris donc en faisant
cavalier pranger k4 ça se dit bo - un
sursis à une attaque et bien forte je
peux perdre du matériel jouer au moins
pris un pion donc si j'étais champion ça
sera à égalité
et si l'attaqué shubin j'aurais
peut-être un pion de plus donc il va
falloir maintenant que les blancs
justifient leur attaque suffit pas de
monter une attaque il faut encore
qu'elle marche donc à l'étranger quatre
dangers de ce parce qu'ils ça c'est pas
mal puisque donc il choisi de naître la
dame puisque les tours finalement il les
a placés au centre dit autant tac avec
la dame comme ça je garde un potentiel
maximum de mes pièces et j'attaque le
cavalier on peut pas jouer ce serait une
très mauvaise chose puisqu'on affaiblir
et 7e ici diagonale et ça permet
généralement on comprend on ne peut pas
reprendre puisque le flou donc si on
joue à cinq on affaiblit son rang pour
rien puisque plus jouer h3 de toute
façon ce qui force le cas il ya partir
donc il ya pas le choix il faut revenir
et la bouffe trop cher trop bien ça y
est le loup et attaque
déjà on ne peut pas jouer il faut aussi
être seimat donc c'est fort pour
l'instant mais ça n'est pas
gagnant c'est à dire que la police n'y a
pas d' attaque directe il n'y a pas de
maths dirait que rien de concret si ce
n'est une augmentation progressive de la
pression un plan des blancs maintien ça
peut jouer autour des 3 contre l'elysée
est touché 3 et sacrifier un g7 suivie
du match fou 17 des noirs pour l'instant
comme n'y a pas de menace directe les
noirs avec justesse continue à se
développer un jour de fou 17 et bel
ibère leur tour pourquoi pas à regarder
mètres la tour après ans et 5 et pouvoir
éventuellement jouer un rôle défensif
sur la 5eme ranger voilà qui là aussi
est une manoeuvre de défense classique
est mis sur les blancs ne tendent pas f5
alors déjà efsa une bouche 7/7 angers et
puis c'est la fin de ce pression qu'on
l'entend parler tout à l'heure on
augmente la pression méthodiquement le
long de la diagonale du fou à la prise
et ne semble pas envisageable parce que
scipion prend 1,5
alors là on a un objet 6 direct alors
puis on prend 1,25 sa main d'oeuvre très
classique on peut envisager d'un médecin
exemple du retour aux 7,1 mesdames f si
c'est peu si possible pour menacer d'un
premier set puisqu'elle fou
potentiellement c'est la dame n'est pas
en prise puisqu'il ya le roi sera un
échec alors met sur pied un problème 5
simplement on peut envisager simplement
de cabaye épreuve 5 c'est fort puisque
cav l'épreuve 5 menace qu à l étranger
cette menace qu'elle les prend 1,6 avec
échec sa force
quasiment la prise f5 et après puis on
prend un f5 tout cédé gonal et super
faible
tout ça est faible ça n'est pas
défendable en fait il ya plus de
matériel pour défendre ça ça va être
très très difficile et qui plus est la
dame peut prendre en bessette est
menacée
7 on a en plus une attaque en bessette
on a la possibilité éventuelle est
encore toujours de tripler les pour
et puis comme ceux qui ont été bloqués
eh bien il n'y a pas de possibilité de
s'enfuir avec l'eau donc on est un peu
dans l'attenté ya pas presque c'est très
difficile de défendre ce type d'attaqué
en fait aussi a pas de complot il suffit
d'augmenter la pression tout seul faux
pas de se presser et c'est très
difficile à retenir donc f5 la prise et
est peu envisageable donc on comprend le
coup suivant de peu de petrossian ça
paraît logique puisqu'il jouera à schwyz
disant voilà il se dégage de cette
diagonale qui était pas très saine voilà
il se dégage ne veut pas rester là non
seulement de la diagonale mais aussi de
la colonne donc son coût défensif
classique donc pour l'instant il n'y a
pas de encore et toujours pas de menaces
directes
donc ce parce qu'ils jouent maintenant
tour des f1 regardez comme il ya
maintenant après avoir enlevé une sentry
il met ses tours du côté droit alors ce
souterrain est dangereux parce que avec
l'idée c'est tôt ou tard de prendre 25
et pourquoi pas envisager des tours
prend m6 puisque en cas de g prend des
années comme g8 m c'est matt donc il ya
comme une menace ses pions
professionnels et e6 pardon et tour pro
cavaliers avec menaces de maths donc ken
une pièce donc il faut réagir
bon la réaction se comprend d'amd 8 de
la part de petrossian
alors c'est un coup passif est ce qu'il
aurait pu jouer autre chose ici oui il
aurait pu tenter encore plus actif
peut-être dans nos cinq par exane 5
puisque dame 5 protège toujours le
cavalier mais la dame n'est pas aux
fraises en des 8
elle est quand même en plein centre de
l'échiquier une possibilité pour une war
aussi pour sortir sutil situation c'est
de réagir au centre un toujours comme ça
vous avez une attaque sur elle c'est de
préparer une réaction sans donc si vous
mettez adam 5 peut-être que vous
pourriez préparer la poussée des cinq
qui à la fois joue contre le fou et
explose un peu le centre blanc si le jeu
s'ouvre au centre sera les noirs vont
créer les contrats menacent cette
centrale qui empêcheront les blancs
d'oeufs continué leur attaques d'amd 8
un peu passif peut-être nouveau gouttes
dans le 5è plus actifs même s'il ya des
problèmes de calcul parce que qu'est ce
qu'on fait sur camille f3 peut-être
autre chose comme une américaine je sais
pas donc tout ça et tout ça et à
calculer f prend 1,6 ici dans cette
solution dans cette position mais pour
ce pas ce qui c'est l'heure de prendre
un e 6 de façon à affaiblir les cases
blanches est ici sous la porte et du fou
et après elle se prend 1,6 regardez ce
parce qu'ils se lancent dans un coup
superbe qu'il faut il fallait voir pour
lancer cette feinte mais c'est
magnifique puisqu'ils jouent le
sacrifice ou 5 alors le coût 5 et un
coût non pas d' attaque
ici c'est un coup de dégagements c'est à
dire que l'idée des blancs c'est de
pouvoir jouer cavalier e 4 pour faire
sauter ce défenseur du rock
alors pourquoi le faire sauter parce que
la femme ne va rien ne saurait tour
prend une cuite
alors là exactement alors imaginons que
les blancs que le noir joue le tournoi
voir la partie des ans
alors les noirs prennent en hausse elles
vont très bien et regardez maintenant
cavalier ou quatre magnifiques
cailleux 4 et menace de faire sauter ça
si les noirs prennent à leucate regardez
la baisse et mat
soyez soyons précis tour prend la fuite
l'échec tout retour forcé et dame prend
j'ai cette technique
1 0 on n'en est pas là après k4
c'est au noir de jouer et ne peuvent pas
prendre le cavalier t4 puisque si les
noirs prennent de qualité quatre autres
possibilités dans ce cas là on joue dame
g6
on peut toujours pas reprendre le
caillou 4 à cause de tout reprend et je
suis de suivi du mat et sur dame g6 que
faire menaces cavaliers prend suivi du
matin j 7
on pouvait aussi pour lui de jouer aux
dames g6 c'est peut-être un peu moins
fort jeu directement cavaliers prendre
alors si on joue directement ici on peut
aussi en véhicule est imprenable l'avait
pas fait on peut aussi envisager
directement cavaliers prendre puisque la
prise est une menace de maths et puis on
menace d'alger 6 6 2 reprend mais c'est
simplement la tour qui prend donc voilà
donc donc le prendre des 4es et punis
par
par la prise ici donc sur cavaliers aux
quatre en fait les noirs se retrouve
obligé un blocage ici blocage en
espagnol donc sur cavaliers ou 4 les
noirs sont obligés de jouer le coup
cavaliers ici h5 qui évitent les prises
en réussissent et qui laisse le cavalier
des quatre ici emprise et qui permet de
protéger g7 puisque maintenant si tout
reprend et fuite maintenant si tout
reprend f8 tour prend une cuite on a un
défenseur de la casse g7 mais c'est un
peu précaire c'est un défenseur qui en
l'air oui et d'ailleurs il suffit
d'appuyer un petit peu le où ça fait mal
damages six ans la dame assise bas et
j'attaque temps cavaliers et mon bébé
sur tu peux prendre des quatre meilleurs
t'as pas trop le choix parce que si tu
ne prends pas je vais gagner une pièce
net fait d'accord donc si on prend des
cadres de la part de petrossian et là on
regarde et magnifique alors faites vous
la main c'est ça oui mais le risque on
reprend le cavalier parce qu on a envie
d'égaliser mais où est ce qu'on peut
trouver mieux vaut mieux trouver mieux
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait regardez
c'est magnifique superbe dernier coup de
ce parce qu' après coop et ancien
mannequin valises chez 5
c'est énorme alors maintenant il faut
expliquer pourquoi parce que bah
pourquoi la menace de menaces très
simple c'est dommage cette date alors
menace damage cette note
bon si les noirs jouent lecavalier 6
pour protéger simplement on fait tout ce
qu'on avait dit depuis tout à l'heure
c'est à dire on fait tout reprend et
bien on menace toujours matt et et
deuxième possibilité si les noirs
prennent cavaliers cave et gsm on prend
le cavalier mais avec l'échec échec
donc il n'y a pas le choix donc les
coûts sont forcés donc c'est pas
toujours déficit c'est pas forcément
difficile de calculer le confort c'est
donc roi g8 et forcé et maintenant
regarder il suffit de jouer dame f cet
échec et le roi va être obligé d'aller
sur la colonne ouverte ça c'est pas bon
puisque après 3h 8 il suffit de jouer
des coups comme tout reste trois menaces
maths et on peut rien faire contre ça
pour la lune noire peut toujours jouer
l'ours voilà ils peuvent sacrifier la
dame si on joue cinq pour contrôler avec
le fou mais regardez comme il y en a
toujours le four b3 ces dames g8 mat
si on joue j'ai quatre pour un péché
tour à trois il suffit de prendre le
pion g4 et la menace tour h 30 est
toujours là voilà donc il faut donner la
donne en fait voilà les données la dame
on n'en parle même pas qu'ils s'amènent
rob mathes de toute façon en quelques
coups parce que le premier tour contre
roye isolé il n'y a pas d'espoir voyez
que ce coup une magnifique donc on peut
pas prendre à cause de ses variantes
d'un prend est suivie d'un mécène qui
reporte le roi sur la colonne ouverte
l'autre possibilité donc on avait dix
étaient six cavaliers f6 simplement fait
tout reprend donc h6 la prise du cabinet
forcé sinon cemac dont on comprend ici
le cavalier est simplement refait la
même manoeuvre robin en f3 ici pour pour
menacer de nouveau dans mon chéri cheikh
dame f7 après que le roi ait bougé suivi
du mat ou que font les noirs c'est
encore objets plus ou moins de données
de danger la dame sûr si on joue ça pour
éviter que la dame reviennent en rêve 7
on joue quand même échec 3 h 7 et on
peut jouer soit d'un match 7 suivi de
toury chèque soit tour tout de suite ici
et ça y est on ferme le cercueil quand l
amont c'est à dire qu'on ne peut plus
sortir et on peut pas empêcher le match
c'est magnifique superoxyde renault
magnifique ce d'or c'est cette partie je
crois cette combinaison est une des plus
des plus connus de ce parce qu'ils bon
je veux dire qu'elle a lieu au
championnat du monde donc elle a fait le
tour de la planète cirque le joug c'est
à l'époque on reprenait les parties de
haut niveau journaux oui oui et on
n'avait que ça à lyon
aujourd'hui on est à l'heure d'internet
mais sur un an
beaucoup d'autres partis à regarder tous
les jours voilà et voilà comment se
passe qui enfin une des parties ce que
c'est parce qu'il a remportée face à
petrossian qui lui donne finalement ce
fameux titre de champion du monde en
1966 et on a raconté ensuite toutes les
épopées de la série de la vie de la vie
de boris spassky depuis son match face à
fischer son retour en france sont
roumains en 92 et puis enfin finalement
sa fuite de la france et en 2012 sous la
pression de la finance internationale et
aider des autorités russes qui cherchent
à déstabiliser la france et non en bref
c'est pas clair tout ça je suis pas
parano nord-mayenne légère tendance
peut-être je suis certains joueurs être
un peu paranoïaque 1 on a vu que fisher
était même peut-être raison ils ont
peut-être leurs raisons sachets serré
mais l'histoire de ce pas ce qui est
quand même assez étrange assez
rocambolesque mais à l'image de sa vie
et 2 et 1 et 2 et de celle des joueurs
qui ont connu à la fois l'union
soviétique ou alors la guerre froide et
tout tous les problèmes qui sont liés à
cette cette distorsion je veux dire du
xxème siècle voilà merci merci j rome
nous avoir accompagnés dans ce parcours
historique de la vie et l'oeuvre de
notre grand champion boris spassky merci
stéphane au revoir de jouer ça la
prochaine fois dans une nouvelle
émission de diagonale tv faut revoir au
revoir